We're going to talk about some topics you may have heard about if you've ever been studying
for the CISV. We're going to talk about the reference monitor concept.
for the CISV. We're going to talk about the reference monitor concept, the security
kernel, and the TCB. If you've ever read about these, you're probably confused. Let me
try and make this as simple as possible for you. It's actually a very easy to understand
concept. Let's start with some definitions. Let's start with a subject. What is a subject?
Well we usually refer to a subject as being active. It's a person or a process that's actively
trying to access an object. What's an object? Well an object is whatever is being passively
accessed. It could be another process. It could be storage. It could be SharePoint site.
It could be a hard drive. It could be a database. The point is an object is passive. It's
being accessed. So subjects want access to objects. If we want to have security, we can
never just let any subject access, any object, and do whatever they want with it because
we never have security. We have to put something in between the subjects and the objects that
will mediate, control the subjects access to an object. Let's just refer to this essentially
as a black box or purple box in this case. It can be all sorts of different things as we'll
understand in a few minutes here. But the important part is we're putting something in between
here that can mediate the access. Now how does mediation decide what subjects are allowed
to access what objects? Well we have to tell this mediation what to do. We have to program
some rules into it. Now as we've talked about with controls, controls should always have
two aspects, a functional aspect and an assurance aspect. So far we have the functional aspect.
We're controlling a subject's access to an object. But we also want to have assurance
that this mechanism is working correctly, that the mediation is working correctly. How
do we get that assurance? Well we could log and monitor what's happening here. So this
concept of a subject accessing an object through some mediation that is based on a set of
rules and all this is logged and monitored is simply the reference monitor concept, the
RMC. So if you've ever heard of the RMC, it's as simple as that, a subject accessing object
through a set of rules that are logged and monitored. Now in security, a concept is great,
but if we want to actually have a control that's going to do something, we can't just have
a concept, we need to implement that concept. Whenever you implement the RMC, it's known
as a security kernel. So the implementation of the RMC is a security kernel. And where
do we have security kernels? Everywhere in security. When you access a building through
a lock or a keypad, that's a security kernel. When you type in a password, user name and
password, that's a security kernel. When an operating system is controlling what applications
can access their data in RAM or access the network card, those are security kernels.
So we use security kernels everywhere in security. Now there's three properties that a good
security kernel needs to demonstrate. The first one is known as completeness. And what
completeness refers to is that it's impossible to bypass the mediation. So if a subject was
somehow able to bypass the mediation, it would completely negate the whole purpose of
this. So completeness, a good security kernel should demonstrate completeness. It should
be impossible to bypass the mediation. Every subject should have to go through the mediation
to access the object. The next property is what's known as isolation. And it relates to
the rules. The rules need to be tamperproof. In other words, only an authorized individual
should be allowed to modify these rules. If any subject was just allowed to modify the
rules to their hearts content, there'd be no point in having all this because you'd be
like, ah, I can't access the file. And I'll just change the rules. So isolation means
the rules are tamperproof. They can only be modified by an authorized individual. The
final property is what's known as verifiability. And verifiability is simply, how do we make
sure that this whole process is working properly? Well, we achieve it by logging and monitoring
what's going on here. And so verifiability, how do we verify our security kernel is working
correctly? It's the logging and monitoring. So that's the RMC and the security kernel. Let's
talk about one other concept, the TCB. What is the TCB, the trusted computing base? The TCB
is the totality of security mechanisms within an architecture. What does that mean? Well, what's
an architecture? John has talked about that an architecture is all of the components
that make up a system. So if you take any architecture, any system, like, let's say, a laptop,
if you were to look at the architecture of a laptop, there's going to be all sorts of
different components in there. There's going to be your hard drive, your CPU, your RAM,
your operating system, your applications, your TPM modules, all of these are components
within the architecture. A subset of those components are responsible for security. So
some of the components are going to be security kernels. Some of them will be anti-malware systems,
based firewalls. Any of these security controls, any of the components within the architecture
that are responsible for security are components within the TCB. So the TCB is the subset of
components within an entire architecture that are responsible for security. And so we can
draw a line around our reference monitor concept here in our security kernel and say that
these are part of our TCB. They're part of our trusted computing base. But are there
other components within the TCB? Absolutely. The TCB is made up of much more than just security
kernels. It's all of the components within our architecture that are responsible for security.
So there you go. That's your quick overview of the RMC security kernel and TCB. And its
subsequent modules will get into each of these components in a little more detail.